let me get to this story I did want to
talk to AJ Hinch about the World Series
but since I saw the story I have to
bring it up to him AJ Hinch denied a
published report TMZ that he was
involved in a heated altercation at the
team's hotel after Game one of the World
Series in Los Angeles he called the
story some nonsense and ridiculous
TMZ citing unnamed sources said that AJ
began yelling and cursing in the middle
of a bar but there was a baseball source
speaking on the condition of anonymity
said the fans at the bar were disrespect
disrespectful to the women in the Astros
traveling party the unruly patrons were
asked to leave the bar Astro security
people called the police after fans made
threats on their way out the door there
was no mention of AJ Hinch his role in
that report but wanted to i in fact i
appreciate the manager coming on AJ
Hinch joins us now one question about it
AJ clear up what happened at the hotel
and then we'll move on yeah I mean it's
a non-story I think I think the
fabrications that can can can get out
for you know whether it's Twitter clicks
or attention grabbing headlines is
unfortunate in our sport so it's you
know laughable comical ridiculous
whatever word you want to put next to it
but it was not of that AJ joins this
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
the difference between what you told
your team prior to Game one and prior to
Game two was what really just be
yourself you know I think I think
there's so much attention and and so
much anxiety that comes around the world
series
just because Clayton Kershaw decided to
be himself and and dominate it and
didn't really take us out of our you
know our goal or our game and I think
our players we recognize that I mean
this is the best of the best on both
sides and and especially I had a good
night it didn't it didn't define the
series and our guys came out and and and
played really well and that was the most
epic game I've ever been a part of and
probably one that will be reviewed in
history is one of the best of all time
do you give motivational speeches
not a lot any more individual side you
know I like my job it's the major league
manager
has turned into so much about connecting
with people and an end of
individualizing this you know every now
and then you'll have a key meeting which
is which is sort of honestly it's just
it's sort of a need just to get
everybody together but not really
baseball twenty-five different
personalities 25 different ways to get
them to be successful like this you know
it's not a huge motivation sport like
football or you know these these we
don't have a half time so it's like
there's a there's a sense that there's a
team component to it yes but it's really
my job to to get the mindset right for
25 different guys I think otic majored
in psychology how do you put that to use
and with 25 different personalities are
you tapping into that of trying to you
know you can't treat them all the same I
think you get to know your players on a
personal and a professional level and
trying to figure out what makes them
tick you know I know George Springer
being one of them how are you gonna deal
with failure and everybody was telling I
mean needed to move down in the ordering
and and they're telling me that he
should and and people you know failure
and our sport is so huge and so most of
it comes around getting into be
themselves and getting him to to attack
the competition and not and not shy away
you know as an example before the game I
tell George you can't play this game
careful can't tiptoe you're an athlete
natural athlete you've got to let it go
let it fly swing like you swing and and
let the results be what they are and you
know Ken Giles is the same he was
awesome for us all fair in the season is
given up a few runs and the attention
around the world series brings this
distension that he's never had to pitch
with before so it's their different
personality some guys need to you know a
pat on the back some guys need to keep
in your ears some guys need you know a
cup of coffee and some guys need maybe a
different coach whether it's you know
Alex Cora or Gary Pettis or Brent Strom
or any of my coaches that go and and
connect personally with these guys
Continental Tire Coach's Corner the
Astros manager AJ Hinch joining us if
somebody didn't see game two how would
you describe it sum it up you know just
emotional is the first things some of
the emotion that was shown
the field is exactly what's needed in
our sport at the moment since like a
moment like that where you know whether
it's you know the pure enjoyment of the
game and the in the range of emotions
that that our sport and sometimes get
accused being boring or just being
flatline earther
everybody wants the players to pretend
like they've been there before but there
was so much excitement on both sides of
the ball especially after you know that
six or seventh inning and and emotional
is the best word to describe that
because I you know these games you know
as much as four cool customers and work
for athletes and we've been in the sport
for a long time this is pretty cool to
be in the World Series and two teams are
left standing they both desperately want
to win it and it came out in a lot of
different emotions during that game how
do you explain Jose Altuve hard to it's
you know I think we can stop talking
about his side that's the one first
thing everybody goes do is how you know
he's a smaller guy I come from found one
of the best players in the game because
of his skills and his work and his
attention and and and to see him get
some national coverage and you know we
could just see it every day we get a
little spoiled and everybody's gonna
check the box that he's gonna get 200
hits next year and and potentially be
the MVP again if he gets the award this
year and I think for us if you take a
step back and see what he's doing on a
on a long-term scale and and he's
putting up numbers that are that are
simply not done when you look at what
happened with the hurricane in Houston
and sort of what was and now what is can
you can you put it into words to this
audience what it was like that you
witnessed at that time yeah it was it
was eye-opening because of the the
magnitude of of the damage you know I
live in the woodlands which is about 30
miles north of Houston and so every day
I Drive the freeway and and you go home
and there's exit every mile and every
exit was closed between downtown and my
exit and and that were 30 miles north of
the city which is probably 60 miles
north of Galveston which is where the
you know where the ocean kind of kids
we should think about that the distance
in the land that had to be covered with
the water you know multiple feet high
throughout our city and I think that
that magnitude when we flew in we flew
over the coast coming from Tampa after
we were relocated for a few days we were
going to be reconnected with our
families of the data Justin Verlander
arrived but there was so much going into
that day but that but the thing that
stood out was the volume of water it
takes to submerge a city and and the
people that are affected by this are
still affected you know we're a couple
months removed from it but it's it's
still you know being rebuilt and people
are still out of their house and schools
are still closed that were that were
ruined by the water and that the
magnitude in the in the City on in one
of the biggest cities that's unknown
where one of the biggest markets in pin
in the country and the volume of water
was was unreal JJ watch done an
unbelievable job raising over 30 million
dollars he throws out the first pitch
tonight what position with JJ Watt play
[Laughter]
before at Minute Maid and and and I was
a pretty good swing so you can either do
a huge athlete you can overpower
everyone but it's even such a supporter
of ours and he's come through our
Clubhouse a couple different times and
and sad that he's that he's not you know
not healthy enough to play his sport but
the fans will go bananas for a lot of
reasons that I in Game three but JJ
Watts gonna get a huge ovation
we got Clayton Kershaw next down or
anything you want me to ask him guys
come if you can skip it starting here
boy that would be the best outcome for
all of us and I had some people who said
that's as good as start as they've ever
seen Clayton Kershaw and that's saying a
whole lot AJ yeah well you know you know
what's funny is and I've watched Clayton
Kershaw through the years and and I love
watching him play except except against
me because is his competitive fires
about as good as to get and and the
thing is that that's frustrating for me
competing against him as I where's the
clinker so everyone said they couldn't
you know he doesn't pitch in the big
games or he's had trouble in the
postseason and Game one of the World
Series was I think we can put to rest
this
notion that he has a problem with the
put the big moment this dude is really
good and can really impact a game and he
took over you know whether it was and we
have a really good offense we've you
know historic offense and he he did it
he did a number on us without any pitch
he wanted to any count the game one was
about him it was a it was a great
performance what's the best pitching
performed she ever witnessed either you
played against or that was on your team
yeah I mean this one will rank right up
there because of the stage you know the
World Series game wanna and Dodger
Stadium you know the the buzz that was
around the matchup with Dallas Keuchel
one of archives it that can hold his own
and I think that I think that's gonna
you know just because of the stage it's
gonna it's gonna rank right up there I
mean I've been around you know no
hitters and in a near-perfect game I
almost caught with Kenny Rogers in back
in the day but Game one of the World
Series in that type of performance
striking out a team that doesn't strike
out can be hard to top that one I
appreciate you joining us and good luck
tonight Thank You AJ you got it that's
AJ Hinch an Astros manager he's good
good I appreciate him coming on because
I thought maybe he might duck out
because he didn't want to address the
TMZ story coaches corner brought to you
by Continental Tire from Sunday rain to
snow and everything in between
Continental Tire is engineered attire
for what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability putting
confidence into driving for more
information location of a dealer near
you visit Continental Tire calm continum
tire for what you do for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]